JAM-PACKED WASHINGTON, D.C.,
SWAMP BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
SO, AS WE JUST REPORTED MOMENTS
AGO, SOURCES ARE TELLING ME
TONIGHT THE FBI HAS IN FACT
COMPLETED THEIR BACKGROUND CHECK
ON JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
ALL 100 SENATORS AND NINE STAFF
MEMBERS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
REPORT, WHICH WILL BE KEPT IN A
SAFE IN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
CHUCK GRASSLEY IS SOUNDING THE
ALARM ABOUT OBSTRUCTION COMING
FROM PROFESSOR FORD'S EXTREMELY
BITTERLY PARTISAN LEGAL TEAM.
THIS WEEK, WE TOLD YOU ABOUT
THIS, THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
REQUESTED ACCESS TO MATERIAL
EVIDENCE OF PROFESSOR FORD'S
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT CLAIM
INCLUDING THOSE FROM HER THERAPY
SESSIONS THAT SHE HAD ALREADY
HANDED OVER TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
ANY REPORTING'S OF HER POLYGRAPH
TEST AND PROFESSOR FORD'S
ATTORNEY ARE FLATLY DENYING THE
SENATE JUDICIARY REQUEST.
SO MUCH FOR A REAL
INVESTIGATION.
TONIGHT IN A LETTER, GRASSLEY
FIRED BACK.
HE WROTE "THE CONSTITUTION
TASKED THE SENATE, NOT THE MEDIA
OR THE FBI WITH PROVIDING ADVICE
AND CONSENT FOR SUPREME COURT
NOMINEES.
IT IS BEYOND DISAPPOINTING THAT
DR. FORD'S ATTORNEYS WERE
WILLING TO SHARE EVIDENCE WITH
"THE WASHINGTON POST" MANY WEEKS
AGO, BUT THIS DAY THEY REFUSED
TO SHARE THE SAME EVIDENCE THAT
DR. FORD RELIED ON IN HER
TESTIMONY WITH THE U.S. SENATE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
FORD'S ATTORNEY DEBORAH KATZ
LACEY ON THE SCREEN, SHE IS A
FAR LEFT HUGE DEMOCRATIC DONOR.
SHE WAS THE ONE THAT WAS
RECOMMENDED BY DIANNE FEINSTEIN
WHO WOULDN'T TELL THE
REPUBLICANS ABOUT THE WHOLE
ISSUE FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS, AND
ONCE VOWED TO SHOW YOU THE TAPE
ON ABC.
AND ACCORDING TO PROFESSOR
FORD'S SWORN TESTIMONY, HER
ATTORNEYS NEVER EVEN RELEASED
NUMEROUS AND PERSISTENT ATTEMPTS
FROM SENATOR GRASSLEY AND
REPUBLICANS TO ARRANGE AN
INTERVIEW WITH SENATE JUDICIARY
INVESTIGATORS.
DEBORAH KATZ IS NOT TO BE
TRUSTED.
MOTIVATIONS AGAIN RECOMMENDED BY
DIANNE FEINSTEIN HAVE LONG BEEN
POLITICAL, INCLUDING MULTIPLE
INSTANCES WHERE SHE DEFENDED
BILL CLINTON AND CREEPY
AL FRANKEN FROM THEIR MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS.
SHE MADE LIGHT TWICE OF PAULA
JONES ACCUSATIONS AGAINST
CLINTON SAYING, JOAN SUFFERED NO
REPERCUSSIONS IN THE WORKPLACE
BECAUSE THE INCIDENT ONLY LASTED
10-12 MINUTES.
HE EXPOSED HIMSELF IN FRONT OF
PAULA JONES AN END WANTED A
FRUIT
FAVOR.
IT APPEARS THAT'S ONLY TRUE FOR
DEMOCRATIC WOMEN.
MEANWHILE, PROFESSOR FORD IS
FACING ALLEGATIONS OF HER OWN.
HER BOYFRIEND BETWEEN 1992 AND
98 IS RAISING SERIOUS ISSUES
ABOUT HER TESTIMONY TONIGHT.
FORD CLAIMED TO HAVE ISSUES WITH
CONFINED SPACES, WRITING IN
AIRPLANES AND HOMES WITH ONLY
ONE DOOR BECAUSE OF PTSD
SYMPTOMS SURROUNDING HER ALLEGED
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
ACCORDING TO HER FORMER
BOYFRIEND WHOSE NAME HAS BEEN
REDACTED, FORD NEVER EXPRESSED
THESE ISSUES WITH SMALL SPACES.
SHE FREQUENTLY FLEW IN AIRPLANES
TO AND FROM HAWAII AND LIVED IN
A SMALL 500 SQUARE-FOOT
APARTMENT WITH ONE DOOR AND
NEVER MENTIONED ANYTHING ABOUT
ASSAULTED.
HE ALSO CLAIMED THAT FORD ONCE
COUNSELED A FRIEND ON HOW TO
PASS A POLYGRAPH TEST.
PRIOR TO A JOB INTERVIEW WITH
THE FBI.
THAT'S A CLAIM THAT FRIEND IS
DENYING.
NOW REMEMBER DURING FORD'S
TESTIMONY, SHE EMPHASIZED HER
TOTAL IN EXTREMES WITH
POLYGRAPHS.
NATURALLY ABC AND CBS, THEY
TOTALLY IGNORE THE STORY.
THAT IS CALLED BY A CIVIL
OMISSION, SHOULDN'T SHOCK US.
MEANWHILE IN A CASE OF CLAIMED
BIAS, "THE DAILY CALLER" IS
REPORTING THAT THREE DIFFERENT
NBC NEWS STORIES ON JUDGE
KAVANAUGH, THREE OF THEM, FACE
HUGE ACCURACY ISSUES.
BY THE WAY, , AND ELECT, TOM
BROKAW, ARE YOU PROUD OF YOUR
NETWORK?
THE BRAND YOU SPENT A LIFETIME
BUILDING?
ARE YOU HAPPY NOW TO BE AN ARM
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
AND AS YOU CAN SEE THE LEFT DOES
NOT CARE ABOUT EVIDENCE, DUE
PROCESS, PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, THE CONSTITUTION,
NONE OF IT.
THEY DON'T EVEN CARE WITH THIS
IMPENDING FBI REPORT WILL
UNCOVER WERE NOT UNCOVERED.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN DOESN'T EVEN
WANT TO SHOW IT TO YOU.
ALMOST ALL DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
AGAINST BRETT KAVANAUGH OR
WHOEVER THE PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE
CHOSEN FROM DAY ONE.
YOU ARE ONLY NOW PRETENDING TO
CARE ABOUT ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
CAVANAUGH BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
STILL STALL THE CONFIRMATION
VOTE.
TO THEM, SADLY, THIS IS ABOUT
POWER AND POLITICAL
GAMESMANSHIP.
WHETHER OR NOT KAVANAUGH IS
GUILTY, IT MAKES NO DIFFERENCE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN PURSUIT OF
POWER.
EVEN SPARTACUS HIMSELF,
SOMETHING CORY BOOKER ADMITTED
TO DURING RECENT INTERVIEW.
>> Judge Kavanaugh: MY HOPE IS
THAT BEYOND THE VICIOUS PARTISAN
RANCOR THAT'S GOING ON, BEYOND
THE ACCUSATIONS, WE DON'T LOSE
SIGHT OF WHAT THIS MORAL MOMENT
IS ABOUT IN THIS COUNTRY AND
ULTIMATELY ASK OURSELVES THE
QUESTION, IS THIS THE RIGHT
PERSON TO SIT ON THE HIGHEST
COURT IN THE LAND FOR A LIFETIME
APPOINTMENT?
ULTIMATELY, NOT WHETHER HE'S
INNOCENT OR GUILTY, THIS IS NOT
A TRIAL, BUT ULTIMATELY HAVE
ENOUGH QUESTIONS BE RAISED THAT
WE SHOULD NOT MOVE ON TO ANOTHER
CANDIDATE?
>> Hannity: IF ENOUGH
QUESTIONS ARE RAISED, YOU CAN'T
FIT ON THE COURT?
IS THAT NOW THE NEW MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
GUILTY, AS LONG AS THERE IS
ENOUGH ACCUSATIONS.
GUILTY OF ALL CHARGES REGARDLESS
OF WHAT THE EVIDENCE SHOWS.
AND IF WHAT CORY BOOKER SAID IS
THE NEW STANDARD, THEN GUESS
WHAT SPARTACUS, THAT SHOULD BE
BASED ON YOUR OWN STANDARDS.
AND EVEN AFTER SHE SAID NO AND
PUSH YOU AWAY, BYE-BYE,
SPARTACUS.
IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO LEAVE THE
U.S. SENATE AND SHAME.
THAT'S WHY WE CALL THEM THE
PARTY OF SMEARS AND I KEEP
BRINGING UP THE IDEA OF SLANDER
AND LIES AND CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION AND FAMILY
BLUDGEONING, ALL FOR POLITICAL
POWER OVER AND SACRIFICING THE
RULE OF LAW.
AND JUSTICE.
THINGS WE SHOULD ALL HOLD DEEPL
DEEPLY.
AS WE SPEAK, THEY ARE DOING
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING TO STALL
AND SCARE SENATOR JEFF SNOWFLAKE
AND OTHERS INTO VOTING
KAVANAUGH'S NOMINATION.
MAYBE IT'S ABOUT TEMPERAMENT,
NOT ABOUT WHAT THE FBI SAYS.
NOW AS WE PREDICTED, THEIR NEW
TALKING POINT IS, THE NEW
CURRENT FBI INQUIRY IS BEING
RUSHED.
NO REQUEST FROM THE FBI, MORE
TIME IS NEEDED -- LET MORE TIME
IS NEEDED AT ALL.
IT'S ALL ABOUT DELAY, THEN IT'S
ABOUT TEMPERAMENT, AND THEN WE
WILL EXACTLY HOW MUCH HE DRANK.
EVEN THOUGH HE DRINKS BEER AND
SOMETIMES STILL DRINKS BEER AND
SOMETIMES DRINK TOO MUCH BEER.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I TRUST THE FBI, I HOPE THEY
HAVE THE LATITUDE AND TIME TO
GET THE JOB DONE RIGHT.
>> THE REPUBLICANS HELD UP A
SEAT WHEN JUSTICE ANTONIN SCALIA
PASSED AWAY FOR NEARLY A YEAR SO
THERE'S NO REASON TO RAM THIS
THROUGH.
THERE SHOULD BE A FULL
INVESTIGATION OF ALL OF THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED, AND WHATEVER OTHER
WITNESSES FOLLOW ON AS A RESULT
OF THE DISCUSSION OR THE
INTERVIEWS OF THOSE WITNESSES.
>> THE SENATE SHOULD ALLOW THE
FBI TO PURSUE ALL OF THE
EVIDENCE AND NOT TO CAP WHERE
THEY MAY GO OR PUT A LEASH ON
THE INVESTIGATION.
>> THE FBI IS VERY CLOSE TO
WRAPPING ITS INVESTIGATION.
THEY COULD WRAP AS EARLY AS
TODAY.
DOES THAT STRIKE YOU AS
SUFFICIENT TIME OR DOES NOT FEEL
RUSHED?
>> THAT WOULD CONCERN ME.
>> Hannity: WE WANT MORE TIME.
LET'S CHANGE THE TOPIC, LET'S
INVESTIGATE THIS OR THAT.
LAST-MINUTE INVESTIGATIONS.
SO YET IN ANOTHER LAST DITCH
EFFORT TO SMEAR JUDGE KAVANAUGH
AND DESTROY HIS FAMILY, SENATE
DEMOCRATS ARE DEMANDING THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
RETRACT THE FOLLOWING TWEET
"NOWHERE IN ANY OF THE SIX FBI
REPORTS WHICH THE COMMITTEE HAS
REVIEWED ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
WAS THERE EVER A WHIFF OF ANY
ISSUE AT ALL RELATED IN ANY WAY
TO INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR OR
ALCOHOL ABUSE.
SENATE DEMOCRATS REVEALED ZERO
EVIDENCE OVER WHY THAT TWEET
SHOULD BE REDACTED.
IN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FIRED BACK "NOTHING IN
THE TWEET IS INACCURATE OR
MISLEADING.
THE COMMITTEE STANDS BITE
STATEMENT WHICH IS COMPLETELY
TRUTHFUL."
MORE BASELESS INNUENDO AND MORE
FALSE SMEARS FROM SENATE
DEMOCRATS.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS THE SMEAR MACHINE, NOW
IN FULL GEAR AND FULL PANIC.
THEY DON'T WANT THIS VOTE.
IT'S REALLY DESPICABLE TO WATCH.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
YOUR KIDS AND YOUR GRANDKIDS AND
THE FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY.
GUILT BY ACCUSATION.
ENOUGH ACCUSATIONS, YOU ARE
DONE.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE FLAILING.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HIS
TEMPERAMENT.
HOW IS SOMEONE ACCUSED?
THINK ABOUT THIS.
YOU ARE ACCUSED OF
SYSTEMATICALLY REGULARLY
DRUGGING YOUNG TEENAGE GIRLS
BEING INVOLVED FREQUENT GANG
RAPE OF TEENAGE GIRLS, WHAT IS
THE PROPER REACTION?
WHAT SHOULD THAT TEMPERAMENT BE
OF SOMEBODY IF YOU ARE FALSELY
ACCUSED?
WHAT WOULD YOU EXPECT THEM TO
SAY, VERY QUIETLY, I'M INNOCENT?
OR DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD HAVE
SUCH RIGHTEOUS INKED
INDIGNATION, ANGER AND OUTRAGE
THAT THEY WANTED TO MAKE IT AS
CLEAR AS POSSIBLE THAT THEY ARE
INNOCENT?
I THINK THE LETTER IS HOW MOST
PEOPLE WOULD ACT AND THE FAR
LEFT MOB IS IN OVERDRIVE.
MAXINE WATERS, GET IN THEIR
FACES.
WELL GUESS WHAT, IT'S HAPPENING.
BREAKING TONIGHT, CONGRESSIONAL
IN INTERN FOR SHEILA JACKSON LEE
HAS BEEN ARRESTED AFTER HE
PUBLICLY POSTED SENSITIVE
INFORMATION OF PRO CAVANAUGH A
REPUBLICAN SENATOR IS ONLINE.
THIS IS EXTRAORDINARILY
DANGEROUS.
OVER THE WEEKEND, WE SAW
SENATOR MITCH McCONNELL
ACCOSTED IN AN AIRPORT AFTER TED
CRUZ, AFTER PAM BONDI, AFTER
SECRETARY NIELSEN AFTER SARAH
SANDERS.
YESTERDAY AT REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN WAS ASSAULTED IN HIS
CAPITOL HILL OFFICE BY AN ANGRY
GROUP OF PROTESTERS WHO PUSHED
IN HIS DOOR.
IN TEXAS, ANOTHER ANGRY MOB
CONFRONTING A GROUP OF PRO
CAVANAUGH STUDENTS AT UT AUSTIN.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
[PEOPLE SHOUTING]
[CHANTING:WE BELIEVE SURVIVORS!
>> Hannity: YOU WANT THIS KIND
OF BEHAVIOR REWARDED?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE OUTCOME
IS?
IT WILL BE MORE AND MORE
RADICALISM, MORE AND MORE
ALLEGATIONS, AND, THESE THREE
REPUBLICANS, WE HAVE OF COURSE
SUSAN COLLINS, LISA MURKOWSKI,
JEFF SNOWFLAKE.
YOU ARE THE ONES THAT ARE GOING
TO DECIDE BECAUSE IF YOU GO
ALONG WITH THIS AFTER YOU GET
WHAT YOU WANTED, THIS IS WHAT
YOUR FUTURE AND OUR FUTURE AS A
COUNTRY WILL BE.
REPUBLICANS WON AN ELECTION, WE
HAD A PRESIDENT THAT ACTUALLY
GAVE THE NAMES OF THE PEOPLE AND
HE WON.
PEOPLE WANT ORIGINALIST,
CONSTITUTIONALIST, CONFIRMED FOR
THE SUPREME COURT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CONFIRMED FOR.
LOOK AT THIS FOX NEWS POLL THAT
JUST CAME OUT, THE ANSWER IS
YES.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE MAKING GAINS
IN THE TOP SENATE RACES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
REPUBLICAN ENTHUSIASM HAS NOW
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WILL
DECIDE THE FATE OF JUDGE
KAVANAUGH, THE FUTURE OF THE
COUNTRY.
YOU WANT TO CALL THESE PEOPLE?
FEEL FREE TO DO SO.
CALL THE HOTLINE, CALL THE MAIN
LINE, I URGE YOU TO BE POLITE.
I THINK THAT'S RESPECTFUL OF THE
OFFICE.
34 DAYS FROM TONIGHT, WE WILL
KNOW THE RESULTS OF THE MIDTERM
AND THOSE FIVE SENATORS CHOOSE
TO GO ALONG AND MOVE THE BAR AND
STOP CAVANAUGH BECAUSE OF
UNCORROBORATED ALLEGATIONS IN
EVERY CASE, NO EVIDENCE IN EVERY
CASE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
THEY VOTE AGAINST KAVANAUGH AND
GUESS WHAT, THEY ARE UP FOR
REELECTION VOTE AND YOU CAN
BUILD AMOUNT.
THIS IS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT WE
WANT TO LIVE IN A COUNTRY IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WHERE
SMEARS ARE REWARDED, AND WHERE
WE ACCEPT CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
WE HAVE NO PROBLEM DESTROYING
POLITICAL LIVES WITH NO
COOPERATION AND IT COULD HAPPEN
TO YOU.
AND AMERICA WHERE WE THROW A
BALL DUE PROCESS OUT THE WINDOW,
WE ARE WILLING TO REWARD THIS
BEHAVIOR.
IF THEY TRY TO MAKE THIS ABOUT
ANYTHING OTHER, THEY ASKED FOR A
LIMITED FBI REPORT THAT IS NOW
COMPLETE, I WILL SAY THEY HAVE
ZERO CHARACTER OR HONOR
THEMSELVES.
THEY WILL BE RESPONSIBLE AS THIS
HAPPENS AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
DON'T HAVE A PLAN.
THEY DON'T LISTEN TO ANY OF
THEM.
ALL YOU GET FROM THE DEMOCRATS
IS, WE KNOW THEY WANT TO IMPEACH
45.
THEY WANT IMPEACHMENT.
THEY WANT ENDLESS INVESTIGATIONS
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       K
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       V
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       N
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       U
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       H
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       ,
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       T
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       E
OR TO AND EVEN CAVANAUGH       Y
WANT TO TEACH HIM.
THEY WANT THEIR CRIMES BACK,
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS, THEY
WANT OBAMACARE.
I WAS THAT WORKING OUT FOR YOU?
THAT'S THEIR AGENDA IN 34
NIGHTS.
YOU HAD TO THE POLLS, YOU GET TO
VOTE.
SEE IF THAT'S YOUR DISTRICT
BECAUSE OF IT IS, IT MATTERS.
AND ASK YOURSELF ONE QUESTION,
IS AMERICA BETTER OFF THAN WE
WERE TWO YEARS AGO?
WHEN YOU VOTE ONE OF THOSE
SENATE RACES THAT YOU SEE ON
YOUR SCREEN, TAKE NOTE FROM THE
ECONOMY TO SECURITY, AND
NATIONAL SECURITY AND TRADE
DEALS AND ELIMINATING BURDENSOME
REGULATION, THE BIGGEST TAX CUT
IN HISTORY.
ALL OF THESE THINGS -- MY DOG
GOING TO COME TO A HALT OF
REPUBLICANS LOSE IN NOVEMBER.
YOU WILL GET THE GOVERNMENT YOU
DESERVE AND IT IS LAWMAKERS
GIVEN TO THESE TACTICS, IT WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
YOU WILL BE REWARDED RECKLESS,